estas botas ya no tienen que las compré
tampoco estas fundas de pistola el
mítico bazar bus de kabul abrió sus
puertas tras la caída del anterior
gobierno talibán en 2003 ahora apenas
hay movimiento en un bazar conocido por
el intercambio de artículos militares
y como puedes ver estos artículos esta
bota es estadounidense
la otra es británica y esto es de abajo
son estadounidenses cuando a los
soldados les daban estas botas si no les
gustaban la forma o el tamaño venían
aquí y las cambiaban por otras con la
salida de las tropas occidentales y la
llegada de los talibanes al poder hace
tres semanas el dinero ha huido del país
a salvo a cada g de trafford cada cama
con el anterior gobierno teníamos muchos
clientes que compraban muchas cosas
ahora las ventas casi han desaparecido
no hay dinero los ricos se han ido y no
hay clientes para estar eso pero no sólo
los ricos han desaparecido también toda
referencia a la belleza femenina bajo un
gobierno que no respeta los derechos que
las mujeres habían ganado en los últimos
años
para fátima hará una perdida doble su
salón de belleza ahora se encuentra
vacío
hasta hace dos meses muchas novias
solían sentarse en esta mesa y había
mucha gente pero como pueden ver ahora
nadie sale de su casa por miedo
fátima pide ayuda a la comunidad
internacional no les queda ningún futuro
dice hecho no nos queda nada no tenemos
libertad no tenemos futuro no tenemos
confianza no tenemos nada entretanto en
las calles de kabul los transeúntes
siguen pasando y los carros siguen
circulando pero nada es igual que hace
tres semanas